[Music]
hey guys what's up how you doing this
morning you know that's like a huge line
out there and a lot of people can't make
it yet so you guys are awesome for
waking up early this is my first time in
front of a live audience people really
in front of any people
boy you're super brave hey cuz you
didn't even practice it you just came up
and did it yeah this is I feel the
nerves doubt damn you have to play still
real right now
what was that that's your role have to
yeah and you didn't practice any way I
could morally tall for this you know you
gotta go like this awkward but you're
used to this position right nice purse
bro
you both did it come together is it
because you guys were fighting all
morning that's what happens so we're
gonna do an off-the-record for you guys
yeah you're ready let's do it we're
gonna talk about whatever yeah my talk
brother over there doing the same [ __ ]
yep I'm like man how does people name
who's here before us right as soon as
TIFF starts talking Joe as disrupters oh
yeah parole where's your instrument you
didn't bring it up
what are you blogging at the wall you're
not you're voting like the wall you
could only get this video on Jay so just
kidding do so so stay tuned they're not
my channel okay so let's start the show
yeah all right so oh that was your intro
that's a legit intro that's that's my
Josh your breakup
hands-down though my breakup video went
so viral it was 24 on trendy something
in Australia thank you what a great you
know goodbye video thank you guys for
supporting you know that was awesome did
pre-roll mid-roll poster all right I
can't win I can't wait till we win a
streaming for that know for sure they
should have a streaming for breakup
videos I think mine was one of the best
out there I think so yeah [ __ ] apology
vias do apology we we had a pretty good
apology video watch our apology video is
pretty hair right for those of you who
don't know you don't need to know what
we did but it was I can tell them if you
want okay definitely the best whoa I
don't get my mic to sound like we just
went completely off no I hear you no
middle ground how many people actually
know what people are dressed as here cuz
I maybe notice Batman and Superman wait
are you two please make over there
okay yeah I know that one filthy Frank
he's an Atari game console oh yeah I
know what that is those are good yeah
are you just an alpha resin thing I like
is you take your ears off that's funny
those are her real ears oh I like his
costume he's a microphone
microphones do you guys have any
questions you want to know about us yeah
let's just talk to you guys I like this
better
I'm so sick of these fools we're like
best friends on camera but it's all lies
because you know people love the fake
friendship on YouTube channel like they
like it when we like pretend that we're
like best friends and then yeah yeah
that's great
we don't have friends either yeah we
have fake friends business friends yes
yeah we pay each other to be friends
yeah so you guys are more important
let's talk to them Paul guy what do you
want to be when you grow up yeah when
you grow up bigger than you are right
now huh you won't be me oh okay so you
want to break up with Jess what do you
waiting for
well let's hope that your alternate
universe turns out different I don't
think you're the same though because you
actually smile that's true no one broke
up yeah so questions any questions yeah
yeah where is Tiger I mean there is that
home with his grandma you just abandoned
him like this yeah yeah absolutely leave
him with the dogs no I was playing
basketball yesterday and he was playing
yeah he was drooling on a basket hey
this isn't you anymore right back I mean
he patrols a little bit yeah that means
so do I but um yeah he was play
basketball he tripped and then he has a
gash on his face I know she has to bring
up the basketball so so yeah you guys
don't think I'm I don't know the real
story yeah that's what I kiss good
question yeah yeah he fell down the
stairs
where's that crooked teeth boy cuter
tiger Isaac let's go show our hands okay
I got two Isaac Isaac Isaac Isaac
he's my cool bro it was pretty oh I saw
that how was the pornhub event it was
interesting I think I think you
understand within the first 10 minutes
and then you're just kind of over it
really was it was hilarious there's one
story where Joe is telling me where like
someone wanna ward and then this really
deep deep brownie and she's like I
wonder if I could make it touch the back
of my throat there's one for DP best
best double penetration for those of you
and she got on stage and she's like I
just want to think of my dad because he
like stepsister and now I do porn and
thanks for watching me take tix and then
she best acceptance speech I've ever
heard know what does anyone thank God
yeah really fine yeah you cried a
performer's yeah crying I think he wants
good mask a performer yeah and he was
like he started crying yeah what'd he do
he think the Lord yeah you think his
agency thinks his wailing crazy yeah
because I'm sure God is up there going
you know what you you're gonna get a gay
award the biggest porn or whatever
that's gay gangbang yeah
and then he cries and thanks God for it
I love it I I think it's best I wonder
if he was in elementary school as a
fifth grader and being like one day I'm
gonna be in a porn yeah maybe his
friends were surrounding him and he's
like oh maybe in the future of the work
forces so afterwards we went to mommy
burger and I was at the bar and I have a
porn star friend that was there her name
is Nikki Huntsman and we used to do
tipsy bartender together and I was
talking to her and this other girl comes
up ssin she's like you guys look
familiar and I guess she watches tipsy
bartender and she's also important and
she's like oh my god I'm so glad I met
you
and I was like oh so you do porn and
she's like yeah but I've only been in
the industry for like two years and this
was so inspiring just like watching
everybody like their names up there and
like watching everybody win awards for
like how deep throat you make a vision
board you just keep going she's like I
think I'm okay at foot jacking but I
don't I don't know if I could really
wouldn't award for it and they were like
I literally like literally there was
this one girl she could not say anything
but would like yeah she was like like
but like this is very inspiring I think
this needs to be our next movie like we
need to follow porn Awards the rags to
riches story of someone who makes it
through polls I think you just want to
watch porn and call it research I do
because you know my story I want to make
that movie where there's actual you know
like sex happening like it doesn't fade
to black
I want to make a movie like that like
it's good that important good acting
it's every 10 years like I'm gonna do
the good form yeah the good one yeah an
actual good one I just heard about this
movie where they actually tried it it's
called a brown bunny we're in the middle
how were you what do you how did you
know he's right it's it's famous close
Sevigny good golly i watch movies I
didn't watch this movie though yeah I
don't watch it either but but I heard
about this movie and it's called brown
bunny and the somehow that one of the
sex scenes the girl actually gives the
lead actor a real [ __ ] and after that
movie came out everyone was so appalled
by it that's what ruined his career
it was never been able to actors and her
career for like ten years
there was a [ __ ] scene but she didn't
know this one they actually [ __ ] on
set and was shown and you see the dick
in her mouth it's not a boy who's gonna
watch that [ __ ] movie the same though
alright but imagine a movie like Rocky
right I mean there's a training sequence
and then like the porn stars like one
day I'm gonna do I'm gonna win that deep
throat award and share mom's like you'll
never win the team photo what do you
hear me you're a stupid bomb you're
about to nothing you look I will you've
got a gag on those dicks you're never
gonna be good enough as yells like a
cucumber yeah she's at the grocery store
instead of the meat market she's at that
grocery store stuff and cucumbers
you know I like this she should get so
now to grocery stores by non-believers
who are like you get out of here you
stop deep building our cucumbers movie
they're selling the cucumbers for way
more than they're worth because oh my
god yeah you just walked into a very
interesting conversation welcome I hope
you guys enjoy
he's gonna wear a lot of earmuffs yeah
to watch anything why isn't that you can
we have the same conversation what all
those friends get to watch it I know
when he's 18
why don't you just become less hot too
because they're gonna be like bro what
[Music]
age can Isaac come on JK news and talk
with us whoo 18 whatever we want like oh
this guy saved five puppies to like and
then they were a double fisting each
other
it just goes that way I don't do that
Marc Marc things in a different
direction someone said I wouldn't I
haven't done that for months person
people evolve online
you're gonna reinvent yourself how about
this danger boys coming out yourselves
they're there they're already editing it
and then we're supposed to have a like
just all the clips put together by
Monday Dec this coming Monday and then
this is boring how did this the film i
filming fight
I want to hear the juice I want to hear
what it was like on stage [ __ ]
awesome was the best project in the
world it's still boring isn't it no no
she wants to get detailed you don't need
tail Thank You Gio it's like you don't
have a real summer my you're like like
how much all the guys so it was yeah
that's good that's details I'm gonna
hear about all that so I could get
people in trouble later oh nice
yeah and Steve was pulling dollar bills
like this right he was like I'm not
looking no he was he was feeding the mob
I'm not gonna say guys wait I want to
hear what's the Cheeseman what's doing
well it gives away something that they
don't want to give yes Nicky you did
want to get me Bo trouble yeah that's
what I said no yeah I didn't know like I
thought like him in trouble cuz he did
security wasn't supposed oh you wanna
get everyone in trouble well Joe can't
get in trouble cuz know something that's
interesting I almost got my Instagram
account taken away from me yesterday
well I started this new series its rear
it was so fun so like I was giving
advice to losers yeah plenty of losers
asking me plenty of questions right I
mean they say they say some stupid ass
[ __ ] you guys saw those questions right
and well I mean we questions like where
one of the questions like oh like I'm
sad I mean like it's like should I go to
school cuz like I want to be an
entrepreneur and I'm all like you ain't
got [ __ ] going for you why the [ __ ] do
you want to leave school yeah you know
well I mean I'm just joking obviously
cuz it's like I'm roasting them yeah
yeah right so so you guys know my
character I'm just kind of like harsh
and I just [ __ ] around like that so I
had a few jokes and one of them was this
girlfriend was like yeah I mean this
girl was like my boyfriend is I think
he's cheating on me what should I do and
I said you should leave him before he
gives you aids right and then I got in
trouble for harassment and bullying what
yeah so that was my first Instagram
police that like Flags your
how does that work yeah I got taking it
out it was it was perhaps me bullying
and then it was a bot so I try to appeal
it and then they're like nods not
appealable
if you zoom out and just look at that
text
what the hell isn't harassment and
bullying if it's like if you look at
that at leave your boyfriend before he
gives you aids just on like a piece of
paper yeah and then you go this is not
bullying I think that's a people in
Instagram or like what
yeah it's facts leave him he's cheating
on you he's gonna give you aids you love
me yeah and another one was it was
basically like hey he was asking me for
workout advice he was like hey Joe how
do you get bigger arms you know and I
was like beating your girlfriend she
boldly all titties were too big in that
picture I don't know I was inspired by
her deep throat or nothing like that
so Joe then you got two strikes or what
happened yeah so that happened right and
then um you know I'm a whiny ass [ __ ]
so what I ended up doing was posting on
the feed I posted the the violation and
all that and in the caption I was like
Kate this is this is what I said for the
joke what do you guys think or whatever
and in five minutes that post got taken
down - Wow so I was freaking out and
then cuz they're like your account has
all these violations it might be a
suspended and stuff sure yeah - call a
medal from Facebook and I was like oh my
god I felt like a piece of my like arm
or something was gonna be taken from me
you know like it was my social media is
my life yeah so I was like what's gonna
happen are we you know am I gonna be in
trouble like am I ever gonna have a
chance to be fair
does this ruin my chances for anything
and he was like it's it's probably like
you have haters and they're reporting
all this stuff so the bots just catch it
because there's multiple people
reporting this yeah and I'm like oh crap
so what's gonna happen is like I guess
when I get back to work they'll process
um what a human will review it and then
see if like I I get in trouble or not
then I move those strikes though if they
removed you start all over or is it
already two strikes well I don't think
my accounts gonna be taken out but
there's like yeah there's like a strike
rule what's okay once a human being sits
there and looks at the context of you
should beat your girlfriend to get
ripped I think they understand he says
that's the one that I actually won't get
taken away because it's domestic
violence
wait why we why no they said that that's
a domestic violence strike and that one
is the one that you can't get away oh it
won't be taken taken away but he says
the other one he's like oh if you wrote
STD instead of AIDS that would have been
fine yeah I see that
I don't see why well I mean it's stupid
why but it's just because like you went
specific and then so now you're
targeting people that have AIDS you
should have gone curable I saw like
chlamydia as soon as that shingle it's
more realistic I see I was wrong Joe
can't get in trouble he gets himself in
trouble I just don't know I think I
think comedies changing right like it's
it's it's it's kind of under threat and
then when I was talking to my buddy over
at Facebook what he told me was they're
under pressure too so what we're going
through they're under pressure from the
government so that's why they had all
these hearings and [ __ ] cuz they're like
hey man if you guys don't control your
social media and your platforms we're
gonna come in and do it and you know
what are they under control well what
are they native control and their hate
speech harassment Russian troll BOTS all
these other things that's happening if
they don't do it then the government is
gonna come in and regulate it so that's
why all these guys are going extra PC
because they're afraid of the government
coming in and putting regulations on the
plateau so you're gonna do a stamp
comedy album call a white leader or what
are you gonna do yeah I was yeah stuck
between that and my mudda beat me tour
okay but yeah
that's okay because you're the victim in
that one oh you're right see I don't
know what to do anymore guys
like someone's really gonna go read that
and start going you know what I do want
bigger arms and they're gonna beat the
crap out of their girlfriend it's like
they don't even have a girlfriend in the
first place that's the joke that's what
I hate about the whole like hey don't
you know people look up to you I'm like
yo they shouldn't look up to these
people especially right like [ __ ] role
model
well what sucks is no one even
understand sarcasm anymore you know all
the things that Joe is saying that's
just obviously he's exaggerating a
painting is [ __ ] around but then
people are taking it seriously and if
you have a sensitive ass [ __ ] at
Instagram that reads Oh
beatbeat your girlfriend's asked to get
rid he's taking that seriously like how
can you take that seriously but those
people are robots dude they sit there
and they have to go through all that
[ __ ] every day they can't go like oh
this one's sarcasm this one's not this
one's clearly this or that is if they
see the text they just have to go by the
rule which says that's what's scary cuz
on text a lot of stuff gets like lost
and other people that don't know your
humor can come in and I think that's
where the threat is right having a
sarcastic text back and forth with
somebody like it gets weird
eventually the emotions help it I know
Mochis helped a lot Steve didn't update
his emoji so he only has like the basic
ones that like first came out and
whenever I send them emojis it's just
squares okay I get cornered I get
question part squares but yeah did did
Bart ever flirt with you guys
accidentally with emojis no he never did
so part has though now he knows how to
use emojis but what he would do he would
like hit people up right like okay for
my girls out there if a guy's like what
are you doing winky face how do you guys
take that like he's a friend or he's
trying to like exactly so because that
way we keep note taken
I'd say okay so I'm older I'm older
right I'm 35 and I was outside of Jay
can't do the barbed upper gate stuff and
in the barbel brigade all of my staff
are way younger so they're always
texting me like these old [ __ ] up here
they're always texting me like emojis
and stuff like that and then so when I
what I'm in charge of reaching out to
other athletes and saying I'm care
at the time and it's on oh I should try
like this emoji thing because they're
always sending me like you know these
kind of things like hearts and the eyes
I'll send people almost a care package
listening you heart oh my yeah what do
you send it I'll send you a care package
and they'll send back like hearts cool
to the care yet to the care be hip to
the cool so I'll start talking to people
and I do like you know one of these
things were like blowing with the
eggplant cinematic plan to the [ __ ]
cool so then he was like hey do you
think you can start hitting up the girls
does I have no luck with the girls and
I'm like well what are you saying
and then that's what I saw the heart
faces about the care package okay you're
gonna get it anyway so part of someone's
younger you try to change yourself to
fit their whole thing well I get the guy
stays you see like a 20 year old chick
and you're like hey that's what you guys
do right you know you know those
grandpa's that have like the clear
glasses and like that i watch with a
Apple watch
I'm like I want to be cool like one of
those you don't talk like a young person
it doesn't work out so well it's it's
also hard cuz so we grew up in the 90s
right and then we're also allowed to say
a lot of like six-letter def words and
stuff and if you take half of my
vocabulary away I don't know who else to
be so now I got to start trying to be
hip to the cool but you skipped like 20
a yard sale yeah our eta rd6 that are
our words we can't say those and more
I gotta count them it's not readily
available in here thus it's not an F
word I'm very familiar with yeah saying
it was all I heard growing up that's all
you're here that's all you heard you
could even simplify down a three-letter
sometimes it's pretty cool - yeah that's
they're keeping it alive they do crazy
little 12 year olds I heard what he call
it the first six day of 69 a halo and
then he was doing I think was doing that
- Casey's dead character so it's the
ultimate humiliation in a video game to
see your character getting tea-bagged by
another male character there is nothing
more humiliating okay it is and also
know I was just Isaac was doing that
like he's a boy no no but he was yelling
at like saying Casey he's treating
everyone equally I would love that
whoa cuz I'm like working on my phone or
something I just hear that I'm like wait
what does that mean and then I see
what's happening tip if you think he's
never drawn a dick with bullets in a
game you're out of your mind
and then his friends shoot - come on
yeah this is really hard for me to wrap
my head around the fact that my kids 11
and he's getting older and I just I
still see him as a baby so it's really
hard so imagine tyka doing that no I'm
ready for it that's what she was talking
about how he was slam dunking all over
the place yesterday kids are gross do
you have rules where it's like cuz
obviously he's playing games
he's probably to express himself
differently aren't there like these are
game behaviors as soon as the game's
over you're not allowed to teabag KC or
G back home one of the cats or or say
suck it tube to your mom or suck it to
the like all that stuff are there rules
like that like I'm pretty sure he knows
that he's never done that right like
just over dinner like in your face mom
no I got in trouble because back in the
day I had the original Nintendo like the
original not Super Nintendo the original
yeah yeah I was six years old I got my
six years the one with two buttons am i
what the one with two buttons yeah yeah
in a duck hunt no that's it
okay so my dad taught me how to play and
I got like really good like I was really
a dick dude at six years old but my mom
could not for the life of her figure out
how to jump or anything and so I play
with my dad yeah she's cute
but my dad would be like your mom's lame
like she can't play like all this stuff
and so after I'd be like mom you're lame
and she's like you can't say that that's
a bad word game like boo dad said you're
lame bro that's how you could tell your
mom's why cuz you didn't beat your ass
to talk to you about it my mother just
let me like no my mom took it personally
and she said that when my we were at
school and my like my dad was away she
would try to play the game herself and
like to figure out how to play what's
she doing boy like this throws it all
across the table oh my god
it's so sad dude you know what you know
what's the heartbreaking thing I
remember playing double-oh-seven with my
brothers and my dad was like I want to
play and then he starts like running
around hitting the wall and [ __ ] and
like after about 10 minutes of this like
I was like hey dad maybe you shouldn't
play that's that like what a little
[ __ ] or five you're like dad it can't
wait for you to play and you're like oh
when you're gonna come home from work so
we could play crew and then when you're
like 11 you're like [ __ ] off dad yeah
grandma was the best she could she'd get
drunk this was later I was like 10 and
we were playing n64 and she would just
stop in the middle of the race because
she couldn't figure out how like she'd
get turned around and she couldn't
figure it out and then she just stopped
and she'd be like you little [ __ ] I
don't want to play this anymore
there was a Filipino on it you little
[ __ ] dude my Uncle Mark wouldn't leave
the room we'd all be playing a
four-player Mario Cart my uncle's
playing with us and then like just like
lap two he just gets up and goes out so
he started smoking a cigarette up we
gotta finish the race dude man Mario
Kart Stokes [ __ ] though because I
remember choking out a friend over Mario
Kart 8th no he's psychologically one
because he would talk so much [ __ ] and
get me angry that I wouldn't mess up my
game and he got me so mad and he kept
winning that I turned around and choked
them before he got to the finish line
so he pointed out your anger issues and
then you choked him with your English
yeah I almost wanted to choke Joe we're
in Florida bumper car go-karts do on the
right they're like okay no matter what
don't bump into people right I don't
don't hit him and then I keep this guy
keeps bumping into is this [ __ ]
and the finally pushes past me and I
just have got that same exactly my
comment stop me [ __ ] so we were
doing the VR racing game right and and
so everyone gets on these like cars and
they can feel what it's doing like
whatever coming out that's how realistic
it is it's crazy yeah right and then
what this guy was doing was just driving
toward us he was going the direct
opposite direction of the loop trying to
slam into us he would not try I succeed
oh you did yeah you would get some cars
up against the wall and keep ramming
them over and over and we'll see what
jolt like you're getting into an
accident yeah I full-blown hit G Oh like
from the front and then just dragged her
against the side it just kept hitting
her I was laughing so hard that I could
my tears were collecting in the goggles
yeah you [ __ ] you Steve because you're
on that wall huh
that he can sure that game they could
come and stop me they could actually
come sorry they didn't they were nice
enough okay think that game they could
have stopped me the guy was a fan of the
Jeff JK so he was laughing - yeah yeah
[Music]
man that shit's fun dude and shreddies
in Florida that's what we're here to do
he had to take a duty it's gonna take a
lotta get out of his costume I wonder if
his only hole is the face so you have to
peel it off like yeah so we got four
more minutes
is that what yeah yeah okay yeah let's
let's open it up to you guys yeah the
last five minutes if y'all want to get
to know us I think I know bus mega I
guess that we did it if we weren't
recording I tell you what it has maybe
some qualities of they you see they were
a biodome very famous person really
famous person I know who you're talking
about
hey could be anyone who's invited though
well a lot of people that we have on
board are famous but this one's a
particular famous one mm-hmm
he sucked the life energy out of me I
like how specific you got to you gotta
say he I meant she'd
[Laughter]
surely he couldn't be that bad nah this
person never went to Sundance I'll put
it like that David so good shut up yes
Bret ma'am Rock oh my god
let's get pregnant everyone go on in
here right now and tell him we want him
on Eminem Gio so mean she like I pissed
her off one time and she said she was
gonna book M&M and make sure I wasn't on
that up or so oh yeah he's like my idol
and like just is how funny he is but
also how intelligent he is I think we
could have a four-hour off-the-record
within my field but what if he was a
dick dude wouldn't it ruin everything
there's B's s he's Jack right now I'll
jump in yeah I die I want William home
yeah do we think I don't do you guys
think about bringing that back well so
the thing was asked the fields is aside
from our scheduling and super busy and
we really want to focus on my stuff like
danger boys and making films and stuff
the other side of it what you guys don't
see what JK news we get a lot of
articles and they're pretty legit and we
can like vibe off of them 90% of asked
the feels questions that we get are
always is my dick big enough literally
poor Julia going through and like yeah
thousands there might be five really
good questions but 99% of it's the same
question did you ever say no I don't
know we should've done huh
well I mean if it wasn't like
a particular thing it's helpful to give
people advice but every girl that's been
on has been said that size doesn't
matter every single girl that we which
is a lie it's not a lie what you're
talking about
it must be for them to keep asking that
question it must they must hear it as a
lie
yeah they hear that's like wow no I I
personally did not like at all because I
didn't like that the aspect of like I
need to give advice because I'm like I
don't [ __ ] know anything like any
Robbins doesn't know [ __ ] either I think
we all just figuring it out I love
giving our Vice because I like to watch
people fail and I'm like I can't believe
you actually listen to me I think that I
don't think anyone out there is has a
more special caliber than even you TIFF
even you know but the point point of
that is that I think that we all make a
mistake when we put people in categories
and go well they got the answers they
know everything I know I don't think
that's a helpful thing I think that I
think that yeah a lot of people know a
lot of things about different stuff like
I probably know how to write a movie
right and then you probably know how to
how to [ __ ] start a business like you
like it stuff like that that we all have
strengths and weaknesses and when we put
them together we can make dope [ __ ] and
I think ultimately for us to feels it
was really to open up and talk about
things that most people don't talk about
so it was it was more so not really like
giving advice but it's more like this is
what I did yeah talking about it from
experience yeah I would rather than like
you should do this [ __ ] up and here's
what I think works for me yeah yep yeah
well guys sorry to announce this but
we're I don't know they already told us
to wrap it up okay
I'm gonna take it take it yeah a little
rebel okay okay we're gonna end this
[Applause]
you better not ask how much weight they
I mean how much better
what's the bench press or anything like
that all right what's a question all
right it has to do with the gin would
they always ask this question how much
do you lift a free three-day pass what
you have to do I don't even know we had
those things I get so choked to the gym
Monday Wednesday Friday at 7 a.m. and
I'll see if I can find it there no no
see you find it you own it you don't
have to find [ __ ] is like we have a
manager it's called a Dodge you just got
a Dodge they they have an own initiative
don't know what they have going on I'm
the one in charge of sending emojis that
people and say okay yeah all right well
guys thank you guys so much for being
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]